prenez que livre bon soir que l'audience
apparaissait trois livres très
différents ce soir rien de vraiment pour
tout le monde pour tout le monde et
histoire de rencontres d histoire de
transmission je commence avec revival
dernier de 20 alors c'est paru chez
albin michel
dans ce livre la question d'un révérend
plein rempli de magnétisme qui arrive
dans une petite ville du maine et qui
rencontre un jeune garçon de 17 ans lieu
l'énergie entre les deux qui passe
l'électricité peut pas ne pas dire ce
mot là parce que c'est un sujet qui au
coeur de revival
par la suite le petit gain est cet homme
là vont se séparer leurs chemins vont se
séparer et cet homme là va vivre un
traumatisme qui va disparaître de cette
ville
ils vont recroiser le chemin du petit
garçon et l'électricité entre les deux
va encore opérer les lectrices priori
laurent seguin si l'électricité qui
devient un troisième personnage entre
dans cette espèce de l'espèce d'univers
c'est vraiment très très fort je dirais
que stephen king commence à prendre
parce qu'il y avait il y avait perdu un
peu son souffle à un moment donné le il
reprend son souffle et là c'est pas oui
on dit maître de l'horreur je dirais pas
que c'est un roman d'horreur je dirais
plus que c'est un bon suspense avec une
fin mais c'est stephen king qui se tient
bien qui va plaire vraiment à ses
adeptes
voila voila euros m'a donné l'amour yeux
alors si tout ce qu'on était dira pas
moins go c'est le premier livre de dany
depuis qu'il est à l'académie française
je pense qu'il avait un peu peur de voir
comment les gens à réagir après ça on
n'est plus dans l'ordre du récit on est
dans l'ain team tout ce qu'on ne te dira
pas mango c'est la rencontre entre un
écrivain et un jeune mango qui est un
africain qui débarque au québec à
montréal à montréal et qui rencontre ce
cet écrivain et qu'il est donc question
parce que c'est écrit même à devenir une
sorte de mentor pour le jeune mango à la
les femmes la nourriture les traditions
l'héritage le féminisme au québec
bon il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
deux choses intéressantes et c'est aussi
une lettre d'amour d'un cri d'amour pour
le québec qui a accusé et donc dany
laferrière à 76 très très bon très
intelligent ses fins et ça fait du bien
de lire ce juste un petit passage par ce
que ça donne vraiment le ton à cela ce
merveilleux roman je les regarde
franchir la porte en me rappelant encore
une fois mes débuts me disant que ce
garçon est plus rapide que moi je suis
toujours impressionné par la capacité
qu'ont certaines personnes d'apprendre
de nouveaux codes et de se mouvoir dans
une nouvelle culture
il stocke il dévore les êtres et les
choses de telle sorte qu'il devienne une
part d'eux mêmes alors c'est vraiment la
fascination aussi que cet écrivain pour
le jeune et toute l'histoire de montréal
du québec se déploie sous nos yeux aussi
on apprend beaucoup de choses notamment
anecdote cette espèce de petite
compétition qu'ils avaient entre pierre
trudeau et rené lévesque ou servir
parfois là dessus parce qu'ils donnent à
l'enseignement finalement ces jeunes
mongo sur la société québécoise
on sait très bon j'aime bien ce moment
voilà puis un cadeau pour vous fait un
cadeau peut vous faire en fin de semaine
à une belle suggestions pied oui c'est
qu'on va se terrer man of two rapidement
et ça ça fera un beau cadeau pour des
enfants à leurs parents tient dont les
chroniques d'une fille indigne de
caroline allard avec des illustrations
de francis desharnais donc des dessins
qui sont au minimalisme est très très
bon car les noirs c'est celle qui au
début des années 2000 avait fait
paraître les chroniques d'une mère
indigne elle s'est fait connaître avec
ça par la suite elle avait publié
plusieurs livres aussi dont les
chroniques d'une fille indigne et là
c'est le tome 2 et c'est la réplique de
la fille à la mer c'est drôle répliques
assassines des répliques auquel il faut
peut-être que moi je m'attende dans le
futur je pense que c'est ce qui m'a
atteint effectivement les chroniques de
phasing la mienne peut-être affreusement
heureuse
chossat se baigner dans un bonne
nouvelle pour nos parents pourquoi pas
voilà alors voilà toutes ces suggestions
bien sûr seront sur notre page facebook
téléjournal 18h sur notre twitter n'en
voyez ça dans quelques secondes claudia
larochelle merci merci beaucoup par la
loi chaque semaine prochaine